A lot of people think that "each other" and "one another" can be used interchangeably.
But actually, they mean different things and they're used in different ways.
The easiest way to remember it...
...is that "each other" is used when we're talking about two people or two things,...
...and "one another" is used when we're talking about more than two people or a group of things.
Here's an example of how the two of these phrases would function in a sentence.
My mom and I talk to each other.
Well, my mom and I are just two people, so we talk to each other.
However, my family members write to one another.
In this case, I'm talking about my entire family,...
...more than two family members.
And when we correspond, we correspond with one another.
So I hope that clears up the difference between "each other" and "one another",...
...and helps you choose the right one for you.